la question posée à la chambre de
l'instruction était simple êtes vous
prêt à modifier les conditions du
contrôle judiciaire du docteur péché et
ce faisant l'autorisé vous à reprendre
une activité professionnelle même
partiel ce matin les juges ont répondu
négativement et ce n'est pas vraiment
une surprise la sphère est sensible
rappelons le le docteur peschier est
mise en examen pour cet empoisonnement
avec préméditation dont deux cas mortels
la défense de l'anesthésiste prend acte
elle rappelle qu'elle avait formulé une
demande mesurer pour qu'il reprenne le
travail
en dehors du département du tour
demandait ce qu'il puisse être
consultant
dans le milieu dans le secteur de
l'anesthésique finalement on vous
l'avait bien préciser ça impliquait
aucun contact avec les produits
anesthésiques ça impliquait pas de
contact avec le bloc opératoire
donc ça ne paraissait pas du tout
inadapté si vous voulez parce
qu'aujourd'hui on en est à 14 mois
d'instruction et ça fait quatorze mois
que cet homme certes libre mais qui les
privait d'exercer une activité
professionnelle
les juges n'ont pas formulé
d'explication à leur refus mais on peut
imaginer qu'ils ont tenu compte des
victimes dont certaines vivent toujours
aujourd'hui avec de très graves
séquelles après leur passage au bloc
opératoire de la clinique saint-vincent
de besançon